[Music]
hi I'm Natalie Bennett former leader of
the Green Party and about to be Green
Party peer in the House of Lords Natalie
thank you for joining us why did you
enter politics I'd been a journalist for
20 years and I always knew at some point
that I'd get out of politics because
particularly reporting international
news you see the same depressing stories
again and again and again and eventually
that really gets you down and you think
I want to change the news rather than
reported I'd always expected that I
would have gone into perhaps the United
Nations Charities NGOs that sort of area
but I joined the Green Party on the 1st
of January 2006 just with the intention
of doing something about the state of
the world and the rest of it it took
over my life from the Commons to the
House of Lords you are entering as a
peer and yet you refer and your
commitment to abolishing the house how
do you plan to achieve that that will be
one of my top priorities to working on
as soon as possible that I will be you
know talking to other campaigners on the
same subject to work out the best way
forward on that but I can promise you
that I'll be acting on that very soon
after I've entered the house I'll be
doing something about it and I'll be
doing something about it every chance I
get
I'll be there to abolish my own job as
soon as possible but no plans well I
think I think you do that you will see
things within days of my going in to the
House of Lords okay have you been able
to make the most of your political
career before entering it have you been
able to achieve what you wanted to
achieve does any politician ever achieve
what they all they want to achieve I
think the answer to that is inevitably
no I'm really proud of what Green Party
collectively has achieved over the past
10 years we've grown from being six or
seven thousand members to 50,000 members
now we peaked at 160 thousand during
2015 when I was leader then we got 1.1
million votes in the election in the
general election which was more votes
than we've got in every previous general
election added together and it's just
this year with the European election we
got 2 million votes so the Green Party
is growing we doubled their number of
councils this year in one election which
is unprecedented in modern times and you
know obviously now is very much the time
in the climate emergency with the
collapse of
in bio and abundance the issues that
we've always been leading at they're
coming to the forefront but what's
really astonishing well most it just
keeps happening again and again this
morning the Labour Party adopted the
policy of abolishing Ofsted which is a
longtime Green Party policy and someone
got to me on Twitter and said oh here
it's lived in policy too and there's so
many policy areas whether it's education
whether it's transport so many areas
that people are simply following a Green
Party policy has led in terms of
equality in terms of things like the 10
pound an hour minimum wage it basically
you can take our 2015 manifesto and it's
now a very broad broadly supported
document across a broad range of
politics the Lib Dems have announced
that there were a vogue article 50 Leyva
have announced that they will have a
complimentary referendum if we had a
general election tomorrow who would you
encourage your constituents to vote for
it's not a very hard question of course
I'm gonna say vote green
the Green Party says very loudly and
clearly unlike some other parties that
the best possible deal we can have the
best arrangement we can have with our
neighbors and friends is to be
membership of the European Union that's
what we're fighting for but we think the
way to achieve that is through a
people's vote give the people the final
say now that we've seen what is actually
on the table what is being offered as an
alternative people should have the final
choice having voted in 2016 so what we
want is a people's vote we want to stop
brigs it will be campaigning very very
hard in that to win to win remain for
the case and then we should have a
general election because you what we
won't need to be is tough on the causes
of rigged sit there are really good
reasons where people voted for change in
2016
people are desperately suffering whole
communities are suffering from poverty
from inequality from a real lack of hope
a sense that they can build a real
future for themselves and you one of the
things that needs to be a big issue in
that election is fixing our broken
political system in the last election
68% of votes didn't count we need to
create a fair functional political
system which is certainly not what we've
got now that should be a big part of
that election but also you know we need
to make rich individuals and
multinational companies pay their taxes
we need to restore public services we
need to create a different kind of
Britain that
operates within the physical limits of
this planet would you enter into a
coalition with labor to have a peoples
though we will certainly work with
anyone who can deliver a people's vote
but we've always said that your
coalition's in our current political
system it's not it ties you to voting
for things you don't believe in which is
not what we want to do we've always said
you're looking towards what's known as a
confidence and supply agreement so yeah
we would do everything we possibly can
to ensure we don't have another Tory
government that's bottom line number one
but what we're saying is not talking
about you know Liv Damon type
arrangements of 2010 when people go into
coalition's and in return for
ministerial cars vote for things that
they explicitly said they wouldn't like
for example tuition fees you know we for
example you're actually opposed to
nuclear weapons we will oppose that but
you know we will also ensure that we
don't have a Tory government do
everything we possibly can to say that
see that doesn't happen climate change
in the environment obviously a central
issue of the Green Party
how would brexit affect the environment
brexit has the potential to be hugely
damaging you we have a situation where
Greens have long been critics for the
Common Agricultural Policy of you know
the European Union but lots of the
things we've been most critical of like
the huge payments to big landowners
those have been the results of decisions
made in the UK now if we do breach that
we're going to both lose that support
for our farmers which also includes
small farmers but we're also going to
lose a huge amount of environmental
regulation protection for our wildlife
protection for the special sites of
special importance we're going to have
the risk of the import of horrendous
American products chlorinated chicken is
kind of a bit of a shorthand now but
you're looking at hormone life space
you're looking at use of large numbers
of pesticides that are already banned in
your opinion and our farmers will really
struggle to compete against those Goods
so there's a real risk there and what
you've also got you know the world is in
the moment pretty well lined up we think
about climate change the climate
emergency in particular you do we really
want to be aligned with Donald Trump
the world knew is has a number of big
blocks in it European Union US China
Russia on environmental issues and on
many other issues I know where I want
the UK to be lined up with and it's
certainly not with Donald Trump it's
descaling
industry and output necessary to combat
climate change um we have been chasing
for years growth in GDP gross domestic
product we have essentially been chasing
in simple terms more and more stuff if
you take for example fashion the volume
of clothing sold in Britain now is
double what it was ten years ago
I don't remember 10 years ago people
walking around naked or in ragged
clothes we don't need to make and sell
nearly as much stuff as we do I'm not
particularly interested in the figure of
GDP it's an actually in nonsense measure
the old feminist line on this is you
know when a man marries his housekeeper
GDP goes down because she doesn't say
work she doesn't get paid for it anymore
I a more traditional environmental one
if you cut down a forest that's good for
GDP because you sell the timber but of
course you don't count the loss of
forests GDP is in launching this measure
so I'm not very interested in what the
GDP figure is what I'm interested in is
doing the things we need to do just
things like
insulating homes energy efficiency for
home so everyone has a warm comfortable
affordable the heat home providing
public transport buses encouragement for
walking and cycling
doing the things we need to do and stop
doing the things we don't need to do
which is everything from fracking to
extending Heathrow Airport any Airport
to exudes
so what we need to do is look at what do
we need to do to make this nation fit
for the 21st century for one planet
living and do those things and stop
doing many of the things like fast
fashion that we can't keep doing so it's
de-emphasizing the focus on GDP possible
within either the current structure of
capitalism or capitalism as a whole what
we need to do is stop all of us paying
the externalized costs at the moment
Primark sells a five-pound t-shirt it
makes a profit on that one chronium
we all pay enormous costs in terms of
the possibly child labor associated with
picking the cotton with all of the
carbon emissions of shipping that cotton
to
chyna to get spun into cloth where this
dyes pumped out into the river and
polluting the river down to Bangladesh
where this hideous garment factories
where workers are treated very poorly
come over to Britain to be sold in the
shop with people who are on the minimum
wage and zero hours contracts all of
those things have costs we all bear if
we actually ensure that every product
every company that makes something has
to include to pay for those externalized
costs they're internalized into the
product then those companies you their
whole economic model changes and you
know Amazon is the classic example you
know Amazon is a parasite it's not
paying its taxes it's not paying to
maintain roads and hospitals and schools
that it needs to have to operate as a
business we're all paying for them so if
we rebalance this they've current
dominance of big multinational companies
and globalized capitalism it's an
inevitable it's a result of policy
choices and we can change those policies
if we do need to disco industry how do
we make sure that that doesn't
disproportionately affect
industrializing nations particularly in
the global south who are if anything
more likely to be worse affected by
climate change I mean I talked about and
I'm always focused on Britain in terms
of having strong local economies in
Britain built around small businesses
cooperatives
lots of local food growing lots of local
manufacturing what we need a strong
local economies for all around the world
if people are going to have food
security a basis of food security is
having food growing food production on
your doorstep a basis of having a strong
local economy in each town is not say
you know a place that relies entirely on
growing cut flowers that contribute all
the local water supplies and that's then
flowing from Kenya to the UK that's a
profound the unstable dangerous kind of
economic system if you have an economic
system there that's a strong local
economy where you've got lots of small
independent businesses all working
together and those independent business
actors the businesses making things you
also have businesses for accountants
solicitors for sign writers for people
who make shows you have strong local
economies everywhere I'm not talking
about all time you know there'll always
be some products like I do like the cups
of coffee today and we're not going to
grow that in Britain
so you know there's some global trade
but you have much more strong local
economies all around the world and
that's a much more stable secure systems
I think that's really the crucial word
for the coming age is security and you
right-wingers traditionally owning that
word and talked about guns and tanks and
goodness elfis nuclear weapons are some
form of security security means being
sure that you can put food on the table
people roof over your head and that your
kids and grandkids will be in the same
situation in a stable climate in a
decent environment to summarize describe
to me a utopian society that you would
like to see your version of that
well utopian of course my definition
doesn't exist we're not going to have a
perfect society but you I would start
with that word security and a society in
which you every human being has a real
genuine chance to develop their full
potential I don't believe our imagining
universal basic income the idea that
everyone should have a certainly being
under put food on the table people who
roof over their head because the growing
income that ensures that given week I
basically believe in human beings and
their capacities and so much of that now
is squashed by our economic systems by
our social systems by our lack of
community let's open up to their human
flourishing with the underlying security
of knowing you're not going to worry
about have to worry about the basics
that's about it thank you very much
thank you for more debates talks and
interviews subscribe today to the
Institute of Arts and ideas at IAI TV
you